hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of our
Twitter readers his name is Kyle Kyle
Van Pelt and he wrote in saying how do
you determine what adds the most value
to your business listen to the question
Kyle I think I may mention this before
but on my way to work every day I try to
ask myself what can I do to add the most
value to my business today and I find
that if I'm doing things too much that
is not adding a lot of value I try to
see does this still need to be done and
if so does it have to be me who's doing
it and again as you're walking to your
office or however you're going in if
you're waking up and you're going off to
your chair if you're working from home
you do want to think how can I add the
most value to my business now in terms
of how to determine that for me what I
do is to think about impact and the two
impacts that I can have is one helping
one person or one client and having it
in a really meaningful way and so
spending you know a lot of time going
in-depth adding a lot of value to help
one person and hopefully touch them you
know change your life or change their
business and have a really strong impact
the other form of impact I find is is
hitting more masses so having a slightly
less strong connection but still be able
to help and reach a lot of people so
example the first one I might help a
client or might help an entrepreneur
one-on-one if it's a coffee meeting and
just try to really dig into their
business and give them some advice the
example of the second one is is doing
videos like this right I'm in my house I
don't I'm talking to a whole bunch of
people hi but I'm never going to meet
most of you but hopefully there's still
some kind of impact that I can have and
give some advice encourage your
motivation ideas to help you grow your
business so when I'm walking to the
office or try to think how can I have
the most impact how can I add the most
value
if I look at some of the things
especially most entrepreneurs if you're
doing a lot of admin work or accounting
work as an example if you do in your
books how much impact does that have
right are you helping people you're
helping one person really in-depth are
you helping a lot of people in a less
impactful way but you're helping more
people at the same time probably not so
there's a lot of things that you're
probably doing that is not helping
people is not having a big impact that
may still need to get done you know so
for me the books have to get done at my
company there's a lot of admin work that
has to get done it doesn't mean that I
have to do it and you want to try to get
to the point where you can either you
eliminate the stuff you don't need
automate as much as possible and then
delegate the work that still has to get
done by somebody but shouldn't always be
you so for these videos for example my
brand is me so I'm on the videos i want
to help answer the question you know you
tweeted me with a question so i want to
answer that personally that's not
something I can hand off to somebody and
say hey Kyle great question here's my
assistant is going to answer for you
right I want to try to make that a
little more personal but there are the
things that I can hand off that I have a
great team and they can manage do on the
run without me so you got to play that
you know I guess that balance and figure
out what should be done by you where
you're adding a lot of value versus what
can be handed off to the people on your
team at the start you know you may not
have a lot of money to hire somebody the
first person I hired was for one hour a
day you don't have to have somebody
full-time you don't have to have
somebody come to your office into your
home it can be part-time really small
you know an hour a day a couple hours a
week just to unload some of the work
that you're doing and give you more time
to free up working on bigger projects
that can help grow your business another
thing I think about when I try to think
about adding value is I like starting
projects and not running project so i'll
get something going i'll come up with a
lot of new ideas that's my main role at
the company now I guess is coming up
with ways to grow the business and all
launching I'll spend a lot of time
testing things out and then once I have
the system
kind of humming I'll hand it off to my
team to continue to run with and then
I'm off to the new project if you're
thinking about value for your business
especially if you want to sell it you
want to have a business that can run
without you in it as much as possible so
you have systems procedures a team in
place structure that the business can
run without you having to be there and
so as much as possible to remove myself
from the day-to-day operations of the
business and focus on new growth and for
me that's adding a lot of value to the
business so I don't know what stage
you're at with your company at the
moment but you want to try to at least
carve out some time every week I call a
CEO time where you're focusing on
projects that will grow the business and
not just running the operations of the
company hopefully I'll helped answer
your question is a great question i
really enjoyed that one for those of you
watching if you liked it please give it
a thumbs up below makes going to do more
of these videos and i love here we have
to think if you want to leave a comment
under the video about how you know how
you determine value and what what tasks
add the most value for you and if you
have a question for your own business
I'd love to try to answer it for you on
leave in the comments section below I
love seeing that come in and love to
hear your thoughts if you won't leave a
comment below so thank you and I'll see
you on the next episode
you